notre bout comme j'ai dit est de faire
croître l'économie
nous avons fait des investissements avec
nos mesures
nous pensons que l'on va voir au niveau
de croissance plus haut les créateurs
d'emplois qui sont nos pme sont laissés
pour compte la diminution de leur époque
était promise n'est pas là alors ces
investissements non par le ministre
mende où sont-ils une catastrophe comme
le laisse entendre l'opposition où comme
le veut le gouvernement trudeau une
façon de stimuler l'économie
daniel tâche à michel bonsoir à vous
trois alors on devait en parler mardi
soir mais évidemment il ya eu ces
attentats à bruxelles on n'a pas pu
faire alors on a besoin de vos lumières
ce soir sur ce premier budget trudeau
daniel quel est le message sévère à un
message à retenir de ce budget qu'est ce
que vous retenez qu'il ya à ottawa et au
canada un changement radical si vous
aviez encore des doutes sur la fin des
années à peu il n'ya reste plus aucun à
la suite de ce budget le virage est
complet il est totale j'ai vu quelque
part qu'au cours des 50 dernières années
le gouvernement le moins
interventionniste qu'on a eue a été
celui de stephen harper là on vient
d'aller carrément dans l'autre direction
intervention massive de ce gouvernement
là il ya le ton qui a changé aussi
considérablement
il y avait dans ce discours du budget
plein mots qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis
une dizaine d'années environnants
notamment environnement culture et
plusieurs autres bref bienvenue dans les
années dites ensoleillé trudeau tâche
alors là quelque chose qui me dit que
vous avez pas trop apprécié ce budget
est ce que je me trouve
c'est comme un retour aux années 70
honnêtement là c'est emprunter dépenses
et répété voilà c'est
l'interventionnisme qui revient comme
daniel l'a dit le gouvernement c'est
l'ami de tout le monde mais pas
complètement tout le monde on voit que
certains dans certains départements
comme la défense par exemple et à des
coupures qui ont été faits et des
dépenses qui vont pas être fait parce
que justement autrement le gouvernement
aurait franchi le seuil du 30 milliards
ils ont jugé que 29 milliards c'est pas
si pire mais reste à voir si les
canadiens ont la même opinion
michel pour vous le message oui bien
évidemment moi je suis j'ai pas la même
conception de l'état que tâche à vous
vous en doutez bien moi je pense pas que
l'euro de l'état ou d'un gouvernement
c'est de se faire le plus petit possible
je pense qu'il est là pour intervenir et
non seulement dans l'économie mais aussi
un rôle important c'est dans la
redistribution de la richesse est il là
monsieur monsieur trudeau renoue avec
une tradition canadienne qui avait
disparu ce sommet sera prêt il ya
beaucoup de transferts aux personnes qui
vise à égaliser un peu les chances qu'on
parle de l'impôt sur le revenu
l'allocation universelle
les sommes qui sont que deux consacrés
aux autochtones des chômeurs etc
il ya une part des nouveaux
investissements qui vaut à cette
répartition là et ça me semble une
excellente nouvelle
oui daniel on parlait de seul de ce
déficit dont 30 milliards de dollars
maintenant on a le chiffre enfin on
n'attendait pas tout à fait 30 milliards
d'achats à raison un peu plus 29
milliards et quelques mignon mais est ce
que ça peut relancer l'économie en fait
est ce que ça peut marcher ce plan il ya
deux théories qui s'affrontent
régulièrement là dessus quand on est en
récession ça peut aider beaucoup
problème c'est qu'on n'est pas en
récession en ce moment il ya beaucoup de
gens qui disent aussi que c'est de
l'argent jeté par les fenêtres que ça ne
donne rien à la condition qu'on pose
souvent ces désherbants oui vous allez
dépenser des milliards
assurez-vous que ce que vous allez faire
c'est pas des trucs d'une journée mais
des projets qui vont servir la
communauté pendant plusieurs années on
nous dit aussi aussi longtemps que le
ratio dette déficit est positif ou en
décroissance n'est pas lieu de
s'inquiéter canada est très très très
près de l'égalité des deux donc ça peut
devenir inquiétant si l'économie a chuté
le moindrement et rappelez-vous au cours
de toutes ces années tourne au père
brian mulroney à ça a pris
un temps fou à revenir au déficit zéro à
éliminer les déficits
jean chrétien réussi à le faire des
promesses vous diront qu'ils appellent
tous à peu près tous ces problèmes dans
leur cour
donc c'est un pari risqué que fait
justin trudeau et peu risqués tasha le
pari oui justement le message qu'il
envoie aux provinces maintenant c'est
bon vous avez peut-être pas besoin
d'équilibré non plus pourquoi est ce
qu'ils se sentiraient obligés de le
faire si le fédéral ne le fait pas on
voit déjà en alberta et 10 non on n'a
pas de vision de budget équilibré on ne
sait pas quand ça va se passer on
anteryon on l'attend toujours
et les oreillers pour ce que michel a
dit je ne suis pas d'accord
oui il y a beaucoup de transferts la
classe moyenne les familles il y avait
déjà des transferts ce monsieur un peu
mais oui c'est plus sûr monsieur trudeau
mais il ya plus de transferts à des
agences à des fonds ou pour des
entreprises vertes ou quoi que ce soit
ou les libéraux vont les distribuer très
généreusement certainement aux
compagnies et aux individus qui sont
favorables à eux qui vont mettre sur
tous ces comités et ses agences alors
moi je vois plus comme la largesse de
l'état mais pas à la l'individu canadien
oui mais est-ce qu'ils apportent à
chaque canton doit on redonne de
l'argent par exemple aux familles qui
sont les plus démunis par ces
allocations familiales est ce que ça va
moi stimuli ça va leur permettre
peut-être de dépenser un peu plus ou de
financer l'éducation de leurs enfants
ou est-ce que six ges est pas un aspect
positif quand même oui ben écoute
l'aspect positif pour les familles j'en
doute pas c'est sûr que ils recevraient
plus si vous gagnez plus de 15000
dollars vous recevrez une allocution
plus grande que ce monsieur un peu et
certains autres aussi il ya une coupure
d'impôts pour la classe moyenne mais on
voit en même temps qu'il ya des
milliards de dollars que on n'a pas
parlé de ça pendant la campagne on
n'avait pas de chiffre là-dessus donner
de l'argent à l'onu un milliard de
dollars pour des réfugiés syriens
on est bien pour les accueillir mais on
n'a pas donné ce chiffre là alors il ya
plein de dépenses qui n'ont pas été
promis
michel il ya quand même des choses qui
sont que qu'enfin il reste des choses à
définir à la pompe a par exemple de cet
argent qui va être donnée pour pour les
infrastructures
on voit déjà plus à se tiraillent déjà à
québec pour savoir est ce que c'est le
gouvernement du québec elles sont les
villes qui vont recevoir cet argent
ça va créer quand même il ya des choses
à clarifier la n'ont de toute évidence
mais c'est pas un problème nouveau ça
fait des décennies ma fois depuis qu'on
a créé ces programmes d'infrastructures
il ya des querelles fédéral provincial
et en particulier avec le québec et ont
deux voiliers des fonds qui avaient été
attribuées par le gouvernement harper et
qui n'ont pas été dépensés parce qu'on
se concentre pas sur les priorités et il
a le gouvernement trudeau est encore là
c'est une vieille tentation de passer
par dessus la tête des provinces pour
traiter directement avec les
municipalités le gouvernement trudeau
dicté ces fonds là on vous donne une
semaine là pour nous donner vos projets
sinon on en voit ça directement
municipalité alors ça c'est il ya c'est
pas clair du tout là quelles vont être
les modalités comment vont s'exercer les
priorités qui va déterminer en bout de
ligne quelles vont être les projets qui
vont être retenues
et dans le fond c'est un problème qui
l'on parle des infrastructures mais
cette querelle de compétences le higgs
existe dans tous les secteurs de
compétence provinciale où l'état fédéral
décide d'intervenir à lens sonic qu'une
autre des nombreuses facettes du
merveilleux monde des relations
fédérales provinciales canadiennes
daniel en même temps s'ils voulaient
tenir ses promesses
le gouvernement libéral avait pas
tellement le choix d'y aller avec ses
déficits et voyez y est allé je n'ai
heureusement disons là il aurait il ya
certains grands mères qui auraient pu
retarder
on ne lui à un n'aurait pas tenu rigueur
j'en suis convaincu comme sur le nombre
des réfugiés il a décidé d'y aller de
gaz d'un être plein la vue à feu fera en
faisant le pari que l'économie va
peut-être prendre que les prix des
matières premières vont être remontés
vous savez seulement sur la baisse des
prix du pétrole
ce manque à gagner de 50 milliards et
plus que pour le gouvernement fédéral
donc c'est le prix du baril de pétrole
remonte si l'économie s'améliore si le
nouveau président des états unis a un
effet positif sur l'économie de
l'amérique du nord bref si tous les six
à son sens au deviennent des réalités
ah oui il aurait eu raison il va
regagner son pari ce sera peut être plus
facile à la prochaine élection mais ou
trois ans et demi d'ici la prochaine
élection avec une économie vacillante
avec le terrorisme avec tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment il va pratiquement
falloir faire un acte de foi tâche à ce
que ça va être facile à vendre ce budget
là parce que là la mise en laine la
suite est déjà commencé et là on a vu
monsieur trudeau un peu partout sur
toutes les tribunes
oui et déjà il répond aux demandes très
je pense normal est-ce que vous allez
augmenter les impôts si justement vous
n'allez pas recevoir les revenus dont
daniel merlet et là il dit non mais
avoir après avoir brisé la promesse d'un
déficit de 10 milliards g aucune
confiance là dedans je suis d'accord que
ça il ya beaucoup de si la dent à un
autre si c'est que le gouvernement
cherche à récupérer des fonds de revenu
canada de tous les fameux paradis
fiscaux qu'ils ont permis pour les
riches mais on sait tous que les ces
gens là ont de très bons savoir qu ils
vont en trouver d'autres
est-ce qu'ils vont récupérer ces sommes
je doute fortement est ce que le taux de
croissance va augmenter comme le dit le
gouvernement je doute fortement
alors des augmentations d'impôts c'est
ça je pense la grande question qui doit
vendre et dire que ça va pas se passer
mais je n'ai pas vraiment confiance là
dedans
bon alors voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
sur ce budget un peu en retard mais
quand même mieux vaut tard que jamais
alors parlons de québec parce que le ton
monte vraiment à l'assemblée nationale
depuis les arrestations de l'upac la
semaine dernière ça sent un peu
l'ancienne vice-première ministre
nathalie normandeau
c'est le financement politique qui au
centre de tous ces débats mais michel
aidez nous à comprendre ce qui se passe
parce que la cac qui accuse les libéraux
d'être un parti de pourri le
gouvernement qui répond ah si durement
là dessus qu'est ce qui est en train de
se passer
la québec il était évident que les
partis d'opposition étaient pour
exploiter le plus possible et ils vont
presser le citron je vous en passe un
papier ils vont extraire tout juste
possible de cette histoire les des
arrestations surtout une dame à celle de
madame normandeau
mais vous savez quand monsieur legault
dit libéraux c'est un parti pourri je
pense pas qu'il entretient le cynisme en
disant ça je pense que il reflète le
cynisme et il dit tout haut ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent tout bas
il ya aucune confiance pas 72 % des gens
sont convaincus qu'il ya de la
corruption partout à tous les niveaux de
gouvernement
et c'est précisément ça le problème
c'est qu'il pense pas qu'il ya que les
libéraux qui sont qui sont pourris mais
que c'est tous les partis en fait je
pense pas que québec solidaire et
beaucoup soupçonnent est là mais il la
défense des libéraux c'est plutôt ça je
pense qui alimente le cynisme parce que
existe pas non non on n'a pas fait ça
ils disent tout le monde le fait alors
ils alimentent évidemment la croyance
selon laquelle finalement quand on est
au pouvoir on fait nécessairement on est
nécessairement corrompus ce qui pose le
corps il ya des abus mais enfin il est
clair qu'il ya quand même des gens qui
font de la politique pour les bonnes
raisons
oui mais il est clair que ça aide pour
françois legault tasha demande que les
sommes qui auraient été ramassés par
nathalie normandeau soient remboursés
d'une certaine façon ça c'est de la
petite politique comme dit le
gouvernement
non non je pense que c'est petit du tout
je pense que c'est c'est à la fois
symbolique mais c'est aussi réel c'est
l'argent qu'il n'aurait pas dû aider à
la réélection ou à l'élection du parti
libéral je veux dire alors c'est quelque
chose que je pense que c'est le moins
qu'ils devraient faire pour reprendre le
point sur le cynisme c'est fort
intéressant parce que c'est le même
phénomène qu'on voit aux états unis qui
produisent l'amour que les américains
éprouvent pour heureusement au québec
qu'on n'a pas quelqu'un de ce genre
l'homme mais si jamais quelqu'un
sortirait de ce genre là peut-être les
gens diraient ben oui on veut quelqu'un
qui n'est pas classiquement politique
qui dit la vérité monsieur péladeau ça
semble pas prendre trop trop là et le pq
et prix là dedans aussi
mais ça ouvre la porte à des situations
dangereuses quand la population perd la
foi dans les aigus si vous permettez un
mot quand la caq demande que qu'on
retourne
plus de cinq ans en arrière pour
récupérer des sommes et écouter on a on
a décidé qu'on pouvait retourner 20 ans
en arrière pour aller récupérer les
centres d entreprise qui serait délivrée
à la corruption de collusion
pourquoi ce serait pas la même chose
pour des partis politiques
daniel il nous reste 20 secondes 60 à
vous écouter depuis l'élection du
gouvernement couillard et à cause
beaucoup à cause de l'austérité il ya un
climat de morosité très grand il n'y a
aucun doute là dessus de discours
politiques
à l'évidence en mer de l'est québécois
moi je dis bon oui un cynisme louis sont
désespérés des trois partis des quatre
parties mais quand c'est le temps de de
voter on l'a vu avec la dernière
élection fédérale
ils ont voté pour le gouvernement
trudeau et dans le dernier sondage c'est
au québec où le gouvernement trudeau et
le plus populaire alors il ya encore et
encore des côtés positifs il faut pas
désespérer merci daniel de votre sagesse
comme toujours
merci beaucoup à vous trois